[Applause]
it's a boy mr macgyver
what are you going to call him
macgruber
a gruber macgyver
the perfect name for the perfect baby
three seconds macgyver
don't you worry magruber
nothing bad is ever gonna happen to you
not on my watch
damn it we're trapped that bomb is set
to detonate in 20 seconds what do we do
magruber everybody stay calm we're gonna
make it out of here just do exactly as i
say casey hand me that paper clip you
got it
jojo grab that twine i'm on it casey
gummer right here jojo that dog turn
the dog turn right by your foot
i'm picking up that dog turd ten seconds
you heard her jojo give me the dog turn
no why don't we need a dog turn that's
my business now pick up the dog turtle
just give him the dog turtle you'll give
me the dog turd yeah casey give me the
dog turd no i can't i'm keeping count
three seconds fine i'll get the dog turd
i just hope i have enough time
[Music]
damn this door is locked from the
outside as soon as that liquid
hydrogen's released this baby's going to
blow sky high what's the plan to gruber
i want to kiss you on the mouth what
ten seconds
okay okay quickly april hand me the
guitar give me the guitar give me the
car come on
okay check this
[Music]
[Music]
but it's out
seventeen
[Music]
the mine door sealed shut magruber
that's not our only problem magruber
once this hydrogen meter reaches
critical this baby's gonna blow okay
this is no time to panic you're in good
hands i've been doing this all my life
for over 44 excuse me 37 years in
october so i'm 36 but i think if you
were to ask most people on the streets
they'd probably say that
right time to focus casey hand me that
copper wire you got it mcgruber
caleb that feather got your grooves
casey cup right here okay great now if i
could just bypass this detonator i'll up
oh oh both of you behind me look behind
you just there are things i need back
there just turn around
and just whatever you see whatever you
find just just pick them up and give
them to me and okay okay i found this
caulking putty here's a battery okay
okay uh you just hang on to those i
think i need to have everything that i
need over here thank you though two
seconds magruber okay that's more than
enough time for me to tie this bandana
back on and then defu
the groove in the store won't budge yeah
i'm not an idiot isaac okay i know the
door won't budge
uh magruber from the looks of this booby
trapped rpg we've got exactly 20 seconds
oh my god you too vicki is that how this
is gonna be
i was just giving you the time yeah no i
know what you were doing and i know who
put you up to it but i want to thank you
both for this because now i know that i
am the only person i can trust so i will
be making the decisions today okay so uh
vicky uh give me the the
uh oh my god they all look like they can
help uh uh um uh
uh
oh i can't do this no i can i can do
this i can do this i can do this
oh
make a decision
okay vicky um uh hand me the shammy him
in the champion him in the chamois
oh my god magruber are you crying oh
what are you what are you gonna tell
everybody
you just tell all your little friends
you know this is not easy
you think you could do better i
literally couldn't do any worse than you
did well then be my frigging guest okay
great be my okay why don't we switch all
right great ten seconds isaac uh uh hand
me all that stuff over there okay just
hit it over
okay okay great anything from over here
can i help you in any way no i'm fine
with her stuff okay great well then i
would just wait over here until the
explosion okay five seconds four
three you're not helping two
one
kaboom
oh i
guess vicky's count was a little
[Applause]
this door is welded shut we're trapped
and from the looks of this makeshift
gamma bomb we've only got 20 seconds
okay everybody calm down just because
times are tough doesn't mean we can't
make it through this without our dignity
intact we just have to stick together 15
seconds right kyle toss me that bobby
pin you got it magruber okay vicki hand
me that key right here mcgruber kyle
give me a thousand dollar interest free
loan what no just do it we're running
out of time i'm not loaning you any more
money magruber 10 seconds okay okay kyle
hand them that watch what what your
watch no i got this from my dad magruber
fine vicki hand me that bottle here you
go
give it a watch give me the watch
here nice casio
hey mickey
watch
fine uh all your wallets wedding rings
all your valuables put them in the sock
now now no no no no no oh what's gross
how much time do we have you took my
watch mcgregor
i got it i got it i got it
okay looks like we got about ten no no
no one
macgruber there's no way out and from
the looks of that c4 explosive we've
only got 20 seconds don't worry guys
nothing bad will ever happen to you not
on my watch
[Music]
vicky hammer that piece of chalk you got
it magruber okay dad that gum wrapper
here you go magruber
turn it over i wrote you a little note
i love you too daddy
piggy hand me that toothpick you got it
okay dad how much do you love me a
bunchy bunch or a little itty bitty
bitty a bunchy bunch magruber great okay
vicky wait then why did you abandon me
well magruber it's a long story we've
got time ten seconds it was a cold
december night
[Music]
why are you leaving
to start a new life with lacey
lacy yes lacey
the perfect name
for the perfect stripper
but don't worry
nothing bad will ever happen to her
[Music]
not on my watch
three seconds macgyver
[Music]
the door is locked macgyver
oh my god
my dad's a dick
i'm out of here
the door's locked
vicky the door's locked how many seconds
before mcgroover fails to defuse the
wall okay this has gone far enough but
seeing as it's mother's day i think it's
time to end our little feud
nina
you are so special to me
you're my rock
you wonder why i'm in my early 40s and
still haven't settled down
i mean i've been searching my whole life
for a woman who is as amazing as you
but there's nobody out there who even
comes close
you set the bar too darn
i love you so much
i love you too picasso happy mother's
day you mean the world to me
and it's just a shame that in our
society you can't marry your own grandma
[Music]
or can you
make me the happiest grandson on the
face of the earth
will you marry me
are you out of your
mind
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sir i still don't understand why we had
to come all the way out here because
lieutenant we need the best
how did you find me
you forget i taught you everything you
know
not everything
[Music]
[Music]
i love you
that was beautiful vicky
cooper
i thought you were dead so did i but i'm
not
i'm alive and i'm putting together a
team
good for you no good for us
and good for america and good for fans
of justice and truth because you're on
that team
alive after all these years
this is just like nicaragua i got shot
in nicaragua don't worry this is nothing
like nicaragua
damn it
i'm gonna go save the world
hello magruger what did you do with
vicky
there are too many guys i need you to
take two of these guns i told you i do
not use guns
[Music]
anyone up for a little trim
no
what are you doing just want to look
good in your coffin
[Music]
[Applause]
two minutes magruber yeah i heard it
vicky jesus nag nag
i'm really sorry sweetie i'm sorry but
gruber can you do this or not
[Music]
take vicky glorious saint help to be
your lawfully wedded
[Music]
[Music]
you